[Musique]
le proto bus s'il est né en fait de la
rencontre entre deux acteurs le pea
paris-saclay étrange lève donc que le
pea via le proto 204 l'idée c'était de
mettre en fait l'innovation au service
de ce vaste territoire qui est paris
saclay et de pouvoir propager la
dynamique d'innovation qui se crée au
sein du proto de 104 puis pour un groupe
comme transdev c'est vrai que le proto
bus c'est aussi l'idée de rapprocher
l'innovation aussi de territoire que
nous nous desservons puisque transdev on
est un opérateur du territoire de
paris-saclay on dessert notamment le
campus urbain et un certain nombre de
lignes de transport public sur la région
le bus est actuellement en chantier on
est en train de réaliser l'aménagement
intérieur
on est également en train de mettre en
place tous les équipements
technologiques que l'on souhaite
remettre à disposition dans le bus et on
travaille également à tout ce qui est
homologuée à sion du nouveau véhicule
donc toutes les démarches
administratives pour pouvoir faire
circuler le bus je l'espère dans deux
trois mois maximum
ça met à contribution un certain nombre
de nos collaborateurs qui réalise
l'aménagement la maintenance du véhicule
donc c'est déjà un petit projet
d'entreprise en soit à l'échelle plus
global pour le groupe
on est sur un territoire assez unique en
termes d'innovation et avec un axe fort
autour de la ville durable
donc c'est vrai que pour nous en tant
qu'acteur justement de la ville qui
servent on a animé aussi ce territoire
aux côtés notamment de le pea ou des
codes des collectivités c'est l'occasion
en fait de créer une plateforme est de
rassembler des gens pour parler de
nouveaux projets d'aménagement de
nouveaux services de mobilité qu'on
pourrait mettre à disposition d'une
manière un peu différente
ludique et en même temps probablement
plus participative en tout cas c'est
l'ambition qu'on a avec ce projet et
c'est vrai que ben on est un groupe on
essaye de plus en plus de collaborer
avec nos usagers pour mettre en place
ces services ça va être vrai aussi je
pense par exemple au tour du véhicule
autonomous et des nouvelles technologies
mais aussi un peu d'imagination et
d'innovation sociale et je pense que le
proto bus c'est aussi l'ambition qu'on
souhaite donner avec le proto 204 c'est
ce côté à la fois techno et ce côté
social proche du territoire